yeah thanks Russell and so thanks to all
of you for coming so I'm gonna be
talking about probably to do with AC 0
and 32 gates so these are my co-authors
on this result and so what's it is all
about so it's going to be about so
essentially it's motivated by these two
circuit classes things that we've seen
multiple times this week so AC 0 and AC
0 with parity gates right so AC 0
circuits a constant depth circuits with
and or and not gates AC 0 with Papa gate
the same thing but you have parity gates
in addition right so these are the
circuit custom in study for a long long
time so among the first circuit classes
for which we prove lower bounds so for
example for AC 0 we know that from the
early 80s we've had these very
influential results that prove lower
bounds for AC 0 starting with the work
of oil toy and first accept sir and
culminating in this very influential
work of first ad where we from which we
know that parity does not have
sub-exponential site AC 0 circuits right
and this is screwed where this famous
technique of random restrictions and
pretty soon after hostage work people
considered what happens if you augment
AC 0 with parity so right you get an
exponentially stronger circuit class and
can you prove lower bounds for this
and pretty soon Roxboro of followed by a
slightly followed by another result of
Smolenski were able to establish pretty
strong exponential lower bounds for this
circuit classes where case of V so these
have been studied since the 80s and we
have exponential lower bounds for them
but let's looking at this and ok I know
everybody here knows a lot about it but
this assume that you didn't know anymore
you would think that these results sort
of subsume those results like you have
an exponential lower bound for a
stronger circuit class but that's
emphatically not the case so the results
on AC 0 are sort of yield a much
stronger qualitative and in some sense
quantitative understanding of the
circuit laws and the results for AC 0
with parity gates so for example in the
setting of AC 0 the result of foster
implies exponentially strong average
case lower bounds for AC 0 we don't have
analog as results for AC 0 with parity
gates the best average case you know
above you know are like
inverse polynomial so much weaker than
what we know for AC zero directly
following on from these strong average
case lower bounds Nissan was able to
construct strong pseudo-random
generators for AC zero so pseudo-random
generators that you that have only poly
logarithmic sit length we have such
results where you see zero and we've had
them since the late eighties but we
don't have analog this results for Isis
about thirty gates the best
pseudo-random generators we have have
seed length slightly smaller than n so
just slightly better than trivial and
there many other such results ok and the
kind of thing that I'm going to talk
about is sort of inspired by another
example of such a gap in our
understanding and this is to do with
what are called size hierarchy theorems
ok so what our size hierarchy theorem so
we all know time and space hierarchy
theorems for Turing machines and so size
hierarchy theorems are unlock these
questions for circuits ok so given a
circuit Class C what I'd like to show is
that function the set of functions
computable by circuits of some size s
and for the purpose of this talk think
of s is a large polynomial in the number
of variables maybe n to the 100 or
something so a set of functions that can
be computed by circuits of size n to the
100 is a much smaller set than the set
of functions computer by circuits of
size n to the 200 ok and if initely we
expect this to be true and in this
language actually it's easily true if
you work with non explicit or
non-uniform circuit classes you can very
easily count the number of functions
that have circuits of size s you can
lower bound the number of functions that
have circuit sizes Square and easily it
follows that there are functions in the
latter class there are not the formal
class okay but as usual in circuit
complexity
non-explicit bounds easy to come by and
what we'd like to do is come up with
explicit separations of this form right
or equivalently I would like to separate
the uniform versions of these circuit
classes and when I can do this I'll say
that I have a size hierarchy theorem for
a class does it make sense
I mean I think what you want really want
to do is have the upper bound be in the
uniform class and the lower bound be in
the non uniform that's exactly that's
what people eventually get like we will
get the Nanyan form lower bound but our
uniform oh okay so what about the
circuit classes that I mentioned AC 0
and AC 0 with parity gates do we have
such results well first of all for AC 0
we do okay so let me go review some of
these results so here's the sort of
bound the first ad that I mentioned the
one can be a TS
so it says that any AC 0 depth D circuit
for the parity function must have size
exponential in n to the 1 over D minus 1
it's kind of a mouthful but it turns out
that this bound is actually tight so so
a hostage shows that any circuit for the
priority function must have the size and
in fact it's quite easy to construct
circuits of this size for the parity
function so the exact great example of a
tight lower bound ok and so it's I'm
gonna give you a bunch of results like
this so instead of stating it for
general D let me look at a very specific
B so first kind of non-trivial case of
this result is the case when the depth
is 3 in particular when these three what
this says is that the AC 0 complexity of
the function the positive function is
exponential in theta or square root n ok
so I have an upper bound something like
2 to the order square root N and I have
a lower bound which is some 2 to the
Omega square root n so I really
understand this and immediately this
implies is the kind of size hierarchy
theorem that I was talking about right
so immediately I know that the parity
function can be computed by a circuit to
the certain size right some 2 to the
Omega well 2 to the order root n but it
cannot be computed by circuits of
roughly the same size up to a polynomial
factor some 2 to the Omega root n right
so I get a separation became circuits of
sizes and circuits of some size
polynomial in s where this s is this 2
to the root n so in fact this here is a
separation between all s and s to the
order 1 where s is less than some 2 to
the root n because you always take the
parity on a smaller set of variables and
you get the same kind of separation this
makes sense
okay so this is I'm sleeping this for D
equals 3 but this is true for all D so
for every D we know by the same result
that we have a sort of a hierarchy for
AC zero circuits of depth D okay and
this is what I'll call a fixed depth
size our equity right fixed depth
because I'm fixing a certain B and then
I'm along the sides to vary what this
does not heal unfortunately is a
separation between let's say circuits of
size n to the 200 and depth 3 and
circuits of size into the well 100 and
depth 4 for example
okay so it's for a fixed depth it
doesn't work across depths okay it turns
out that we also have such results for a
C 0 so we have something much stronger
in some sense right so polynomial sizes
so they're these beautiful results of
Ben and Kisuke who showed up on ie that
for any polynomial sizes AC zero
circuits of sizes and here there's no
dependence on that the depth can be
arbitrary from a strict subclass of AC
zero circuits of size s to the 1 plus
epsilon for any epsilon I want okay so
it's qualitatively a very different
result right because this is computable
in some fixed depth okay
in fact it's depth to okay and even if
you allow a larger but constant depth on
the other side you cannot compute it in
size yes
so in fact this what the result looks
like there's a function which can be
computed by a DNF formula size n to the
K but cannot be computed by any constant
depth formula or circuit of size n to
the K minus X so I want explicit
separations in all this right so it's
not we're counting right I want an
explicit example such a function and
like we said it's essentially the click
function so been showed lower bond so a
click function but there you have n to
the K which is n 2 K over 4 or something
but if you want this kind of strong
separation because UK actually looked at
hyper graph variance of the click
function
so I believe it can be any polynomial
but it's probably slightly beyond that
when we hang to the log n or something I
don't know it's yeah I don't know not
all right so this is the kind of stuff
we know for AC zero right so in my
opinion the size hierarchy question in
some sense it's been very satisfactorily
answered in the setting okay but what
about AC zero with parity gates right so
here the setting is very different the
answers we have a much weaker so just
going back again to the exponential
lower bounds from the 80s so results of
rasberry of and Smolenski for example
they should lower bounds for symmetric
functions of these kinds let's say the
mod 3 function where you're summing up a
collection of n bits and you want to
know if it's 0 mod 3 or not or the
majority function they again have
exponential size but these exponential
sizes are just a little weaker than what
we got for AC 0 ok so it's it for
example for DEP 3 so I'm going to stick
to the DEP 3 throughout my talk it's
something like exponential into the 1/4
and just to recall for AC 0 the
corresponding bounds something like
exponential in rooting just slightly
weaker but it's likely because enough
because the upper bound that we have is
actually much much worse than this right
so the best upper bounds we have for the
mod 3 function something like 2 to the
order root n this is actually a c0 upper
bound we don't have any better upper
bounds for a c0 with parity gates and
for majority it's actually even worse
okay so the lower bounds in this setting
do not match the upper bounds like in
the theorem of hostile ok so as a result
you don't get the kind of size hierarchy
theorem that we got for a c0 immediately
from hostas theorem you get something
slightly weaker okay so what we are able
to prove as a result of all this is a
quasi polynomial fixed step size here so
it's definitely weaker we don't even
have a fixed depth polynomial version of
it and this is kind of the corollary of
our result is that we had sort of able
to close this gap in our understanding
between a c0 and a Caesar with parity
gates we are able to prove for all
sub-exponential size - a fixed depth
polynomial size hierarchy theorem for
every fixed depth D been able to show
that there are explicit functions that
have circuits of size maybe s to the
order one and here
can be any polynomial in fact
sub-exponential but do not have circuits
of sizes equal in T what we are able to
do is be able to have the explicit
functions something like majority or
more three or whatever for which we can
prove tight lower bounds for AC 0 with
para tickets any questions about the
resides cocaine no sorry I said again
the upper one for majority mason 0 so
it's it's like it was the an exponential
root n its exponential square root of n
log N or something yeah yeah it's
roughly the same but yeah it's a little
bit worse yeah alright so this is the
main sort of okay this is a this is a
main motivation it's kind of a corollary
of our main result and so what are the
functions that we actually look at to
prove this result and these functions
actually are not defined in some sense
by exactly what they do on every input
but by a property they have or by a task
they solve and this task is what I call
the coin problem so what is this so what
I'm going to do now is going to be a
slight digression where I tell you about
the coin problem and then I'll come back
and tell you a little bit about how this
fits into the size hierarchy T so what
is the coin problem so it's an extremely
simple problem okay it's a very natural
problem so essentially we have a coin
with us this coin either has bias maybe
1/2 plus Delta so it's heads slightly
more often than it is tails or bias 1/2
minus dead so its tail's slightly more
often than it is heads okay and so what
we're what we're doing is sort of n
independent tosses of this coin right so
somebody just tosses the same coin so
it's the same bias n times and gives it
to us and what we want to do is devise
an algorithm a that takes as input the
sequence of coin tosses and tells us
which of these is the case is it heads
more often or is it tails Menaka
so that's the coin problem alright and
this number n which is the number of
coin tosses we get I'll call the sample
complexity of the circuit
ok so that's also something we'd want to
keep track of
all right so that's the coin problem so
I hope you'll agree with me that it's an
extremely natural problem yeah anytime
you want to for example reduce the error
of a randomized algorithm you're solving
a coin problem it's an extremely
naturally occurring problem it's of
course closely related to the majority
function because how are you in a most
natural way solve this problem you will
take something like 1 over Delta squared
many coin tosses and compute the
majority that's how that's the most
natural way to do it this is probably
the best way to do it in terms of the
number of samples okay but it's not hard
to show probably a very classical design
that no matter what you want to do you
need 1 over Delta squared many samples
in order to solve this problem so it's
kind of sample optimal it's a pretty
simple solution but what we are
interested in this result is about the
circuit complexity of this problem so
how hard is it to solve for different
class of circuits and once again this is
we're not the first people to look at
this right so it's like in fact it has
been implicitly or explicitly studied by
Allah by a long line of work ok so
starting from the 80s where they were
results on converting randomized AC 0 to
deterministic AC 0 results on computing
the majority function with mono to
inform Euler's more recently works on
hardness amplification and other results
on constant depth circuits all have sort
of angry tones branching programs all
have looked at this problem ok so
implicitly explicitly so just defined
explicitly by this result of brodien
verbum but it's really appears in this
whole line of work and so what we are
interested in is understanding the
complexity of this problem in the
circuit model of AC 0 with parity gates
ok so if I'm interested in this class of
circuits what's the complexity of
solving this Delta kind problem ok so
throughout Delta is going to be this
parameter which measures sort of the
bias of the coin so I'm interested in
Delta is the parameter going to 0 and I
want to understand the complexity of the
problem in terms this Delta so again I
can try to implement this sort of simple
majority solution as an AC 0 circuit or
AC 0 parities of yet and what will they
give me well I can do the majority of
something like 1 over Delta square coin
tosses and if you remember majority has
a circuit of size slightly more than
exponential in root n so this will give
you an AC 0 circuit of depth 3
it's not an easy zero parity so it's
just an AC zero circuit no parity gates
of DEP three and size something like
exponential in one over Delta that's
just something I'll pop out of this
what's interesting is that you can do
better than this okay so this is not the
best you can do
okay so if you're restricted to the
model of AC zero with parity gates doing
the majority is not the best way of
solving the coin problem you can do
something better and this is something I
find surprising okay so there is this
and this follows from these beautiful
results of O'Donnell and women and
Kazuki who show that for example the AC
0 DEP three complexity of this problem
is bounded by exponential in square root
of 1 over Delta okay so you as opposed
to this a trivial solution you gain a
square root in the exponent and in
general for every depth D you gain a
square root in the exponent so O'Donnell
Bimmer actually did this for depth 2 and
Kisuke sort of extended this for all
constant depths
so I'm gonna tell you a little bit about
their construction and then go on to the
application to size Iraqi theorems so
what does what are these formulas of
o'donald women and Kazuki amano look
like so they're actually conceptually
very different from the majority
solution right so the majority solution
how does it look you pick some like one
over Delta Squad coin tosses and you
compute the majority function so it
looks like something here are the
solutions extremely different so it's
the formula they construct in fact takes
an exponential number of samples okay so
it so it's a large formula it's of
exponential size but it's so but it's a
read ones formula so every leaf of the
formula is a distinct variable okay and
so you computes like an exponential size
read once and or nth formula in these
exponentially many variables and it
turns out somewhat magically that this
ends up solving the coin problem so I
don't want to get into these parameters
here but it's an extremely explicit
formula that's something I want you to
take home it's conceptually a very
different solution from the majority
solution for solving problems related to
function it's it's sort of related to
ache yeah but it's not the same thing
it's it's not it's not that it's
computing some problem that's true you
can do that but this it takes advantage
of something even more than that in some
sense so we'll get to that in a second
so I'm assuming that I know Delta
exactly right but but this solution it's
a monotone solution it's so it also
works if you have a sort of an pound on
Delta function which is
the photonic and examples that we should
be difficult so yeah it's well this one
is sort of balanced right we have the
degrees are little bit different in
between it's not well so I'll get to
that maybe in a little bit yeah so okay
yeah it's not exactly the substr
function the degrees of these formulas a
little bit different oh but it's a very
simple formula sort of a very regular
graph and at every leaf distinctly
forgot you have a different variable
that's it okay so it's a very explicit
function so back to size hierarchy
theorems so let me tell you why this is
related to size hierarchy theorems okay
so just to recall so what did we want in
order to prove a size hierarchy theorem
for AC zero with parity gates right what
we wanted to do is we want an explicit
function for which we can prove tight
lower bounds this weren't really doing
size hierarchy theorems means okay and
standard lower bounds like for example
the majority function they're not tight
so what do we want to do we change our
function class all right it turns out
however that if we are looking for tight
lower bounds for ec0 with parity gates
there are examples of this form already
occurring in previous literature okay
and our sort of search for this is
guided by these examples okay so what
are these examples these are the
so-called approximate majorities okay so
what are approximate majorities so very
unfortunately these are not the same
approximate majorities that have already
featured prominently in this workshop
the slightly different set of
approximate majorities
so what you'll forget about those and I
will be defining it in a slightly
different way so an approximate majority
here is a function that's approximately
the majority function okay so that's
what it is so it's a function on n bits
which agrees with the majority function
on 90% of the inputs okay so that's an
approximate majority yeah it's much more
worthy of the name in my opinion but
anyway okay so these are approximate
majority all right so so it turns out
that many interesting things we can say
about the ac0 parity complex do you have
approximate majority okay
so interestingly and this is related to
the coin problem and as I'll describe in
food coming slides so what O'Donnell
memorandum on Oh showed in these results
for the coin problem is that there are
approximate majorities which have AC 0
circuits
of depth three and size something like 2
to the N to the 1/4 yeah again if you
want to be the majority exactly the
right answer maybe to the root n but
here it's 2 to the n - 1 forces gain and
interestingly this is tight now even
with parity gates okay so why is that
well it's actually just a facet of the
razbolo Smolinski sort of method for
proving your bounds so how do you prove
lower bounds whereas bro Smolenski
method you approximate your circuit by a
polynomial and then you show that
majority function cannot be approximated
by polynomial right but in this method
all you're using is that your circuits
are have only approximate the majority
function right because anyway
approximating it by a polynomial right
so same method works and you can show
that any approximate majority must have
large size and what was that size from
before it's the same thing it's
exponential 9 to 1/4 okay so we have
tight lower bounds so that's great the
problem however is that these functions
are somewhat non-explicit okay and
that's the problem we want to overcome
then we want to prove tight lower bound
for explicit okay so let me just go
through this construction approximate
majorities and we'll see where the coin
problem comes in all right so let's just
see how this construction of O'Donnell
vemma and mono works how did they
construct these approximate which are
peas somewhat not explicitly really
answer the following so suppose I want
an approximate majority right and I want
to compute it with a small circuit okay
so here's the hypercube well if I wanted
to be the majority function I'd be one
on top and 0 on the bottom but now I'm
allowed to in a few places okay so where
will I air and as we said the right
place to err is where majority is
hardest to compute and that's close to
the middle right because there that's
yeah question okay sorry
so so you want to air in the places
where the majority function is the
hardest to compute right so so many of
the middle so what do you do you throw
away maybe a small part of the meal ok
and we're not allowed to err on 10% to
the hypercube so I can throw away
something like maybe through 10 layers
in near the middle and I'm still ok I've
only thrown away something like maybe
10% of the height so I throw it away I
give up on these inputs and what I'm
left with is computing majority on the
bottom part here in the top part here ok
and you
that I don't have to do it exactly I
only have to do it approximately I'm
gonna make use of this right okay so
this is the idea right so I want to now
compute majority I want to say 1 here
and 0 here it is approximately and now a
natural thing to do is to try sampling
ok so what do I know about these let's
say this layer of the hypercube that I'm
calling l1 and this layer l0 where I
know that for any input X and l1 the
number of ones is something like n by 2
plus epsilon root n so random bit is
going to be 1 with probability 1/2 plus
something like 1 over root N and
similarly for a point in l0 a random bit
is going to be 1 with probability 1/2
minus 1 over root N and really
distinguishing between these two things
is sort of solving a coin problem right
that's exactly what I sort of reduce the
problem to if I want to sort of
distinguish between inputs in this layer
and this layer by sampling then what I
really need to do is solve the coin
problem for a certain value of Delta and
what value of Delta is that something
like epsilon by root so that's the
observation that if I hide a circuit or
some function that solved the Delta coin
problem where Delta is something like 1
over root n then what I could do is I
could use this to distinguish between
points in l1 and points in l0 how I
would start with my circuit I just plug
in random bits for my input I just use a
bunch of inputs input bits at random I
just plug them in to see and if this
input happen to come from l0 then these
bits would be like 1/2 minus Delta
biased and these inputs happen to come
from l1 there'll be 1/2 plus Delta
biased ok so in either case this would
agree with the majority function most of
the time because it solves the point so
does that make sense
yeah so it's not going to be explicit
because of these choices of i1 to iron
it's a random projection of the circuit
that makes a non explicit right yeah but
it's clear that this sort of now can
approximate this brain because on inputs
on the top is going to accept with high
probability inputs in the bottom it's
going to reject with high probability so
random circuit but now by averaging you
can fix some values of i1 through iron
so you get a deterministic circuit that
has the same
property and that's it so that's the
construction so you start with a circuit
that solves the Delta coin problem
what's the Delta something like it
should be 1 over root n sorry Delta is 1
over root n right and we had these
circuits as I said a few slides ago of
size something like exponential in
square root 1 over Delta yeah and you
just plug in the parameters you get some
sort of circuits for an approximate
jority of size into the 1 exponential in
n so this construction I hope was
reasonably clear right so that's a
simple reduction from approximate ease
to the coin problem
the unfortunate thing about this
construction at first is that it's not
explicit right so I choose these random
projections and then I have to fix them
sort of I mean by averaging and this is
not explicit ok so what I'd like to do
is come up with explicit functions for
which this goes to right and one way of
doing this is D randomized this argument
just come up with these I 1 to I n so
that this works deterministically I
don't know how to do that ok but I know
how to do something a little bit weaker
and that's what we'll do in order to get
the final separating example so but five
minutes left so maybe I can describe the
separating example I won't do I won't go
into the proof and then so what is my
separating example going to be well it
is guided by the proof that I mentioned
a previous slide so we said previously
that if we start with a function that
solves the coin problem and then do
these random projections we get an
approximate majority right so now this
part is non explicit but then why not
start with these functions directly and
that's the idea so instead of working
with the approximate majority you sort
of go back to the source and work with
the circuit that solves the coin problem
so this circuit computes some function
on some capital and many inputs right
it's clearly size optimal right it's
clearly size optimal actually size
optimal for two reasons one of these is
interesting and one of these is very
uninteresting the interesting reason is
that from this circuit I can sort of
project down and get an optimal circuit
for an approximate majority so it can it
is definitely size optimal it cannot be
made smaller there's a none interest
reason why it's size optimal is that
it's a socket right it's a circuit of
size n on n variables so of course it's
size optimal right so of course I can
use this in order to prove a size
hierarchy theorem but I'll end up
showing that circuits on
I mean functions of n variables cannot
be computed in less than in size okay so
this is not what I want wanted to do all
right
so in order to make this idea work I
just need one final twist is that I want
a circuit of this form which is no
longer read once I want to reduce the
number of distance and pulse that my
circuit takes and still has the same
functionality it solves the coin problem
right and if I hide that then the entire
thing would go through and I've got a
size high repeater okay and so you can
view this as a sort of a partial D
randomization of the construction that
we saw if you can get n all the way down
to 1 by Delta square then that's a full
D randomization but if I again end down
to something maybe a little bit larger
but still interesting for the size
hierarchy theorem then I have some sort
of a partial D randomization it's
somewhere part yeah oh so I don't want
to increase the depth in doing anything
yeah so I have to be really careful for
increasing the depth right so we do yeah
so we do reduce the number of samples
but we actually have to
deterministically fix these X's to
various wires yeah okay so I don't think
I'll have time to go through that but
anyway let me state the main technical
designs so the results the following so
the Delta coin problem can be solved by
depth three formulas for example of the
same size as before but now the number
of samples comes down from exponential
in 1 over Delta the polynomial in 1 over
Delta it's not the right polynomial is
not 1 by Delta squared but it's some
polynomial and 1 over Delta it's very
explicit I mean yeah so is the edge
connection language or whatever can be
solved in poly
so it's very explicit right and the
second theorem is that there's a
corresponding lower bound which is that
any AC 0 mod is 0 mod 2 circuit of depth
3 for this problem must have size
exponential 1 over square root so the
second theorem
you've sort of been following along what
I said the second theorem you might
think why is this non-trivial because
anyway the way we constructed this coin
problem it felt like solving this coin
problem I mean it's like lower bounds to
this coin problem just follow from lower
bounds for approximate majority but in
that thing I cheated a little bit I sort
of assumed bread functions were monotone
if you don't assume that functions I'm
gonna taunt and be a little perverse
about it there's actually a lower bound
question hiding here and you can solve
this question sort of nicely and give an
optimal amount this way okay
and I should say that this is sort of
closely related to this level one
Fourier coefficient bound that we have
spoke about a few days ago so from his
very nice work with avi Shia Shan and
Shahar Lovett and so you can show that
this is kind of equivalent to the fact
that low degree polynomials have small
level 1 Fourier coefficients yeah and so
I sort of huffed and puffed a little bit
and showed this direction but very
recently I wish I'd shown me a sleek way
of going from the level 1 Fourier
coefficient bound to the proof of
theorem 2 that's really the right way of
thinking about it so it's kind of like
the level 1 Fourier coefficient okay so
I think that that's all I have time for
I'm probably out of time at this point
so let me stop with the statements of
main results I just did you a couple of
open problems so so we wanted to prove
size hierarchy theorems for a C 0 with
parity it's right and one way presumably
to prove these theorems is to prove
tight lower bounds for mod 3 or majority
very really explicit functions like that
I don't know how to do that so I went to
the coin problem and I did a whole lot
of other stuff but this question I think
is still interesting and worth pursuing
and another sort of interesting question
is to get the right sample complexity so
as I said I know how to get sort of
explicit AC 0 mod 3 form or ec 0
formulas of polynomial sample complexity
for this problem but it's not the right
polynomial in fact the polynomial
actually depends on the depth of the
circuit which is not true sort of non
explicitly non explicitly I can show
that I can get the sample complexity
down to 1 by Delta square so very nice
to do that explicitly that's all I have
[Applause]
so let's take their speaker again
[Applause]